the Oscar class of 2023 came for a
celebratory lunch and a Tom Cruise love
Fest for dessert welcome everyone to
Entertainment Tonight it really was like
Hollywood had a homecoming just for Tom
it looked like all the stars just
couldn't get enough of them yes and all
the nominees made sure to get their
moment with Oscar's Top Gun
[Music]
I was like was that Tom Cruise no that
wasn't no it wasn't but it was and it
was
and I was like oh my gosh he's like the
living son we were thrilled he showed up
he's filming Mission Impossible he's up
against it but it's so great that you're
really clear so much about Top Gun that
he came uh away from England
long hair tan skin and a three-piece
suit Tom surprised everyone in his first
major event in eight months we see you
Whispering with Austin Butler shouting
up Michelle yo then cruising right into
the iconic oscar-class photo his arm
around former Mission Impossible Fallout
co-star Angela Bassett Steven Spielberg
praised Tom for ensuring the Top Gun
sequel was released in theaters
you're here
look closely there's Michelle Williams
seated in the front just a few nominees
away from Spielberg Kate Blanchett is
top left in the same row a double fist
pumping Brendan Fraser and smack in the
middle a proud Jamie Lee Curtis
Jamie also had her moment with Tom she
got a kiss on the hand and was clearly
shocked and also starving we fixed that
I didn't eat I don't love him I'm so
happy the first time nominee put down
her slice to reflect on the Monumental
honor she might have missed out on if
everything everywhere all at once shot
away from home I have a family I have a
dog I have a husband notice the order
that I said and I don't mean that in any
way disparagingly to my sweet husband I
have a life here and I have to leave it
all the time but because it was Los
Angeles and Michelle yo was going to be
Evelyn I said yes immediately who do you
bring Sunday to the Oscars I'm bringing
my husband Christopher Guest okay
forcing him to to go with me poor guy do
you have an outfit picked out do you
have an outfit a costume yes Dad I have
an outfit to wear and by the way Mommy
buys retail oh yeah
back on the carpet it was a double dose
of debonair when Austin also posed with
fellow first-time nominee Colin Farrell
Colin and his banshees of inner shear
and co-star Brendan Gleason told me the
day was one word surreal I don't know
that anyone in that room actually
believes that they deserve to be in that
room there's a little bit of how did we
all sneak in did the bouncer see me it
was a day date for Austin's Elvis
director baz luhrmann he's nominated
with his costume designer and wife of 26
years Catherine Martin I want to bring
up Austin his performance in Elvis
tears keep flowing I was not gonna make
the film and as I found someone who
could play elves rightly so Priscilla
was quite cynical about how this young
kid could in fact manifest her husband
and I'll never have a more
nerve-wracking screening than when we
screened it for Priscilla she said if my
husband was here he was a hot damn you
Army you can't overstay the level of
acting achievement for Austin Butler
back inside kiwi Kwan posed with
everyone everywhere all at once
including Tom Cruise his Indiana Jones
director Steven Spielberg Encino Man
co-star Brendan Fraser and Causeway star
Brian Tyree Henry miss his business
you did this movie Causeway with
Jennifer Lawrence Jennifer Lawrence is
very familiar with the Oscars
when she found out did she call you and
warn you about tripping on any stairs
she probably did tell me not to trip
when we were filming this movie in
between texts she would always be like
you're gonna get nominated for an Oscar
and then just walk off you get nervous
about what else he's gonna have a
permission her words have power
[Music]